here's something you probably won't see
at the World Cup you see it's called a
gold Olimpico it's a direct goal scored
off a corner kick see how the ball curbs
pulled off a player needs to kick the
ball from the corner of the field and
bend it into the goal without the
assistance of any other players they're
super rare and when they do happen it's
usually an accident I mean look at this
you're aiming for an opening you can't
even see the only way to do it is to
bend the ball you know like David
Beckham David Beckham swinging it right
it both Olympiakos are almost impossible
to find out what makes them so rare I
kick the ball with an Olympian yes got
some pointers from pro a lot of hip
motion through the ball and talked
soccer ball aerodynamics with a
scientist so as you start changing the
circles the now I haven't really played
soccer since I was a kid so I got some
tips from Brandi Chastain she's a
two-time Olympic gold medalist and World
Cup champion these days she's an
assistant coach for the women's soccer
team at Santa Clara University Brandi
you scored a few goals in your life
right a few once or twice yeah Chastain
scored the game-winning penalty kick
that won the World Cup for the u.s.
women's team in 1999 she showed me the
finer points of bending a corner kick
well first I'll ask you are you left
footed or right footed definitely right
footed then we're on the proper corner
one of the first things to do is figure
out which way the wind is blowing you
you recognize that the wind right the
wind is gonna be pushing into the goal
so it's important that you start the
ball out just outside of the goal so
that the bend will bring it back in and
by Ben do you know what I mean by that I
think you're meaning I need to put some
swerve on the ball yeah you need to put
a little love a little texture easy
enough right
you got some things going for you good
good noises like that got to have a
little umph on it
you got good Bend now we just have to
make sure that we get you in the right
direction okay so my first attempts were
not great just getting the ball out
there was clearly going to be a hurdle
aim right
gonna come back this way oh come back oh
now it's just the ink
we got the distance now we just need
that through Cheston showed me how she
divides the ball into sections so she
can kick it with power and precision the
ball can be split into four quadrants
and basically then manipulated by by
where you hit it so if you hit the ball
straight through the middle it will have
this kind of motion if you hit the ball
underneath it will have this kind of
motion and likewise from one side to the
other will have this kind of curving
motion and now for the tricky part if
you take that and now you create like
the third plane which is you go from one
plane up through another plane now you
not only get the spin but you get the up
and then then down you can basically
take the ball and make it turn whatever
way you want it to depending on the
placement of your foot on contact so the
ball can do all kinds of amazing things
depending on how you strike it so what
do I need to work on well it's not just
you Robby what what you need to work on
it's what all players need to work on is
the the balance between the force that
you put on the ball and the finesse that
you you give it kind of the love that
you give the ball as Chastain says it's
force and finesse but in scientific
terms it's something called the Magnus
effect I've got the ball spinning like
this the Magnus effect says if the air
is flipped off to the side over here the
air that's being pushed this way has to
be pushing the ball in the opposite
direction that's Newton's third law so
if you see a ball coming at you spinning
like this the front part of the ball
tells you which way it's going to want
to move so if it's spinning like this
it's gonna want to move the direction my
fingers show we're basically talking
about the effects of spin it's the same
physics behind a curveball in baseball
or a slice in golf it's even used by
some basketball players without the
Magnus effect there would be no goal
which isn't to say that they're easy to
master I had every advantage when I was
trying the wind was in my favor there
was nobody in the goal box and I had
expert advice on spin from Chastain
maybe it was the ball now I know what
you're thinking this guy just isn't very
good at soccer and yes you are totally
right but the balls design particularly
the number of panels and seams can make
a big difference in the way it flies
scientists at places like MIT and NASA
have actually looked at this and the
issue is something they call roughness
and anyone who remembers the
controversial 2010 World Cup Jabulani
ball it was exactly what I mean the
reason there was controversy over the
java lonnie is when you start reducing
the number of panels on the ball you run
the risk of making it too smooth think
back to the Magnus effect remember how
it whips air in the direction of its
spin that's only true for rough balls
ones with lots of panels and seams but
smooth air balls like the Jabulani they
deflect air less consistently and if the
ball is perfectly smooth you can
actually whip air in the opposite
direction producing a reverse Magnus
effect now spin isn't the only way to
manipulate a ball flight path if you
want it to move unpredictably you can
kick it with little to no spin that's
called a knuckleball just like the one
in baseball Chris we hand a midfielder
for the San Jose Earthquakes showed us
how it's done simply come back and
strike straight through the ball and
hitting it more with your laces rather
than with the inside of your foot is
kind of the best way to hit it you just
kind of let the the seams and the design
of the ball kind of do the magic you're
very little areas are on the side and it
starts to separate with the boundary
layer delaying on the rough side that
means it's going on line moving toward
the rough side so you can get this
wobble happening when the ball has a
little bit of turn and that wobble can
be an advantage
for penalty kicks but back to my quest
to kick the elusive goal Olimpica stain
brought in a ringer to show me a few
Monty
this is Kelsey Turnbow she was our WCC
freshman Player of the Year
she also happens to play with our one of
our youth national teams here for the
u.s. technically she's a lefty but she
can do this right footed as well Turnbow
definitely had better form than me I am
better finesse plus she can kick with
both feet she can really bend the ball
towards the goal and her shots went in
after dozens of tries I finally managed
to kick a goal Olimpico myself alright
so it bounced a bit and it was hardly
under game conditions the goal was wide
open so if you see one in a game
remember that the reason they're so rare
is that all the skill and science of
soccer have to come together perfectly
and that's why they're almost impossible
when you look at the elite players they
they have they naturally will factor
those things in because they've done it
multiple times they understand the
elements and they understand the
circumstance and when it is the right
time and when it's not the right time
and if it isn't the right time you'll
absolutely you'll see it you'll you'll
see the outcome because it won't be
closed and when it is the right time
it's a thing of beauty
[Music]